He,
before we even get started,
I got to give a shout out to this dude,
Aaron,
where is it?
Where's the,
uh,
not that,
but he gave us that.
But the other thing,
the white snake,
oh,
there it is.
I told the story a long time ago about a
car accident and I got into when I had
a,
I had an older girlfriend.
He's telling me what to do,
which is pretty hot though,
Stephanie,
how are you?
Um,
and she,
uh,
she made me throw away this whitesnake
cassette after the car accident.
I had a little box of cassettes in my
car and she said,
throw that out and that's fucking listen
to her.
All right.
So if you're in that state,
if you're in that situation right now,
will your interrelationship and the
person you're with tells you what to do
and you go,
fuck man,
I'm that bitch.
Why was that bitch wants to,
and I was bummed out,
man,
that I fucking threw out this whitesnake
cd wells cassette cassette,
rather they would,
I didn't even have a CD player then
that.
When did they,
when did cds come out?
Officially
90,
80.
I feel like we've done 88
trying to figure this out before.
We just don't,
it's just not worthy enough.
Somewhere in the 80 [inaudible]
yeah,
early or late eighties,
I would say.
Cause I got my first one in,
I remember for my birthday when I was
like 16 or something like that.
17.
So this had to be
b,
a d eight.
Cause I know that after I broke up with
her,
I started fighting again.
I took like a break,
we broke up and then I have three more
fights after a date of her.
So,
uh,
like kickboxing fights.
So I remember the year,
uh,
so I'd had to be Ada,
which is 88 or 89.
But fucking,
I loved this cassette.
So that was,
that was like a real moment of for me.
You know,
there's moments when you haven't
relationships where you'd go,
fuck,
I can't be this guy.
I can't,
I can't just let someone tell me what to
do.
And someone tried to change me.
Like she was a very smart girl and she
was older than me.
Like she was 25 and I was 21.
And I remember,
you know,
she was just smarter than me.
It lists,
it's certainly at the time more worldly
than me and uh,
I just fucking listen to her.
It's not good man.
Don't you hate when you see your friends
in those situations though?
Like you see the friends that are,
that always fight every week and they're
always breaking up in there.
Yeah,
it's awful.
In her defense,
I was a fucking idiot in her defense,
so I,
she was trying to shape me up,
you know,
it was an interesting like,
you know what I knew I couldn't hang out
with her anymore,
was um,
there was an incident at a comedy club
that I've told before.
I don't want to repeat it again because
the person that I talked about,
like [inaudible] talked about it in the
Jamie Kilstein podcast,
the person I was talking about is
completely delusional and their
perception of these events,
I don't want to even rehash who the
original person was that I'd gotten this
dispute with,
but I wound up walking off the stage
because I was disgusted by how this
professional comedian was censoring
people at an open mic night.
And um,
Stephanie,
who's,
by the way,
awesome.
Never anything but awesome.
She was very cool person.
So I've never hated her or anything,
but she,
you know,
she pulled me aside and she like Kinda
like lectured me.
She's like,
look,
if you want to do this,
then you have to really do it.
You can't walk off stage like that.
That's completely unprofessional.
And I'm like,
I'm not a professional.
I'm like,
I'm an amateur.
Like,
yeah,
it's unprofessional.
I'm trying to learn how to do it.
And then I realized like that's not how
you talk to people that are in your
life,
that if you don't like what they're
doing,
like you have,
there's,
there's gotta be a better way of
approaching it than that.
Her way of approaching it was from like
a mother perspective,
I can authoritative perspective,
you know,
it was weird.
It was a weird relationship in that
respect.
And when you see those relationships,
the problem is
not,
I don't want to generalize,
but oftentimes in relationships,
the dynamic that the relationship begins
with is the dynamic the relationship
sticks with.
And if you get stuck in a relationship
where one person is telling you what to
do,
it very rarely goes back the other way.
And then you tell them what to do and
then they listened.
It never does.
It's like you develop like a chief and
the rest of the Indians,
you know there's a captain and then
there's the sailors and it's just the
way it is.
Man.
I don't know why,
but with her,
like early on she assumed the role of
the one who is like dictating what was
okay and not okay,
what kind of music I should like,
how I should dress.
It's real weird man.
But again,
she wasn't a bad person.
She was a 25 year old girl dating a 21
year old guy who was crazy.
And you know,
when girls are 25,
they're like,
okay,
what am I doing?
Am I going to marry this guy?
I'm going to have kids with this fucking
idiot.
I got to shape them up.
I've got to get them to stop listening
to white snake.
I mean,
I think I do that every almost every
relationship though.
Like oh yeah,
she uh,
you know,
and then coincidentally you often dig,
always great girls younger than you.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
Always and never fixable.
Like as hard as I tried.
Not that fix of all
21 to 25 is,
um,
it doesn't seem that old,
like for a guide.
What girl?
And again,
I don't like to generalize,
but I definitely think that girls mature
quicker than guys.
100% oh yeah.
I think that's common knowledge,
right?
Well,
I've been trying to figure out why.
I've been trying to figure out what it
is.
Parents,
man.
No,
I think it's ego.
I think men have spent so much time
coddling the male ego worried about
this.
Fuck,
go fuck kicked.
This guy's us.
You know?
Fuck that guy up.
Like posturing and presenting themselves
like especially when they're really
young as something better than they
actually are.
It's like a big part of being a young
man until you realize somewhere around
your thirties I guess that nobody buys
that.
Like nobody buys that.
Like when you're posturing and you're
pretending to be someone other than you
are,
you think you're giving yourself some
sort of weird comfort or trying to,
but it's like sucking your thumb.
It's not really effective.
It's not really doing anything.
Women don't have that.
They don't have the,
I'll kick your ass.
They don't have the this guy.
What does guy think he's going to fuck
my wife?
It was his gun.
I think he's going to take my job was
this guy thinks he's going to fucking
move in next to me and put up a fucking
fence in front of mark.
Fuck,
that's my fucking,
but when men get this weird thing,
man,
they get this weird male thing and women
don't get that thing.
They get different.
They get pitched things,
they get,
they get a,
they get their own thing.
You know they get the bitch at each
other but it's not,
this is not nearly as like physical for
the most part,
you know,
it's much more likely that two man are
going to throw bones.
Then two girls like when two girls
fight,
it's like Holy Shit.
They went for it.
They like physically trying to claw each
other's eyes out and usually at least
one of them is out of their fucking
minds.
If you get two girls,
obviously not talking about martial arts
competition,
but if you get two girls involved in a
street fight,
at least one of them is out of their
fucking mind.
He said the best like to sane dudes
under the right conditions with alcohol
involved could beat the shit out of each
other.
It's very possible,
very possible,
especially with alcohol involved,
but two girls pulling hair and club,
I would venture the vast majority of
women out there have never been in a
fistfight because vast majority,
80% yeah,
I think that's a good number.
I think 80% of kid number,
it's probably not right.
So they,
I think they're,
they're,
you know,
they have different,
different things going on and I think
even if they want to be respected and
they want to be appreciated,
it's not the same as like the male
thing,
the male wanting to be respected,
especially our young men.
It's very difficult to get over just the
natural monkey instincts that boys have.
Just those natural monkey instincts.
There's so God damn distracting.
That I think is maybe this is just the
theory,
not even biologically why women be sure
in general faster than men.
It might just be this,
the lack of the struggle with that male
ego.
Yeah.
Brian and I talked to him about it.
Is it?
Do you ever have male instincts to like
buy a girl's neck when you're having sex
with her like that,
that kind of,
that seems like you'd be somebody that
would be like a neck bite or you'd be
really into it and just go,
do you not want you beaten off?
Thinking about how I fun so I will stop
this conversation right here.
It's,
you know what,
it's,
it's different with different girls,
right?
Isn't it?
With different girls you dated.
Some girls like to get choked.
They just do.
I hate all that.
When a girl tells me to slap him or
choke him,
that's the word.
I can't do it.
I'm not going to beat you up and going
to have to get that from somebody else.
You're going to have to call her Ari.
Do you think the daddy thing,
there's something there.
When girls are like,
fuck me harder daddy,
when is the whole daddy thing?
Do you think there's something to it?
It's a dirty,
yeah,
it's dirty.
They don't mean their dad.
They mean you.
They want you to be their daddy in that
moment.
Not even like a father,
but like,
like the data that's given the Dick,
you know,
they don't even think it's like a
different word.
It's a different use of the word Daddy,
you know?
It doesn't mean the same thing.
It's like when you call someone captain,
sub captain,
you don't really think that guy has a
boat.
But what if they follow me?
Yeah,
I told her.
But the thing you say,
there's one girl says it as a kid though
and she doesn't talk like a kid in any
other times except when she's having sex
and he's like,
Hey,
she request is into like tolerable.
Yeah.
Well she dating you.
Some dark shit happened.
Yeah,
but see I go deeper in it.
I was like,
yeah,
you're like daddy for school wise while
you're fucking her.
Yeah.
Just to see you leave for school.
I mean like I'm going to try to go down
that path.
If she brings it up,
I'll see if she plays along.
If she plays along,
it's like fun.
It's like trying to learn more about
this person that I'm fucking,
you know what's even more disturbing
saying are you leaving for school?
Cause that means it's morning sex.
Like the dad doesn't even have the
excuse of being drunk
coffee and fucks his daughter.
That is God.
Yeah.
Just not your homework.
You need to find better people,
but you know,
you gotta work on yourself.
Right.
I know.
Get your own shit in order and you'll
attract people.
I don't make a noise.
I just don't breathe.
I slobber in their hair and I
don't do anything.
Do you still take those pills?
I,
you know,
I stopped at when I started sharing
playing boner pills,
uh,
gas station,
boner pills,
boner pills specifically.
Brian has like some gas stations picked
out in the valley that he travels to
have Chinese drugs in them that make
your dick a totem pole.
Yeah,
they,
they're very sketchy.
Uh,
you can go to fda.gov and see all the
ingredients and all the ones that
they've tested and,
but I stopped doing it when I start
tripping.
Like I,
I actually saw visuals,
I think I've talked about it on this,
but recently they've had new packaging
where they're like,
holograms and like they're,
they're awesome packaging.
Like it's a horse running or,
or,
uh,
like black stallion.
A good one.
Here's a question.
How much do you think it would cost us
to randomly test the gas station pills
that you take and then read the results
on the air?
It probably have some right now that
you've saved.
Just packaging in my car.
I say about 30 different ones in my car.
But you have the packages.
Okay.
Set aside one package of each one that
you really enjoy blacks down here right
now.
I want to set these aside and I want to
see how much it costs.
I'll go through the u s uh,
the UFC labs,
whatever they use.
I think they use their Nevada state
athletic commission I think uses quest
diagnostics,
but they test blood,
they test blood and urine.
We can't do that,
but we'll find out a place where we
could send it to a lab to get the
contents.
Analog Sda has done well on,
it's done it.
So I'll just use,
I'll use whatever guys on it's done.
But FDA has done it for these ones that
you're taking,
do you think they're the consistent,
like they're not the same every week.
They change.
You could tell they change their
ingredients sometimes.
Like I had one burst open my mouth the
other day and it tastes like tea,
but I've had it before where I burst
open my mouth and it tasted like pills
like inside of a pill,
like a chemical neurol.
Um,
they're all powder inside.
Some of them are powdered.
There's the one that I had the other day
was like a t,
like almost like weed inside.
But are any of them uh,
gels,
like,
uh,
they're all seem to be like a powder
inside and,
but like these new ones,
like the latest one black stallion where
it has like a Hologram of a horse
running,
uh,
that one legit four days a boner solid.
And like,
I was like really studying it the other
day.
Cause it's,
it's,
it's just like every single pocket of
Shit on your Dick.
It's just full.
It's swollen.
Like it's,
it's hard though.
It feels uncomfortable.
Like it doesn't feel like you're normal
dick,
where it's like,
oh this is comfortable.
Super high dose of Viagra.
I don't think it's my anger anymore.
I think it used to be,
I don't think this is by,
I think this is like some kind of
reaction cause it's like my dick is
swollen up.
Like it's got got bit by a snake.
Oh it's powerful though,
man.
I like girls can tell immediate like,
like holy shit,
that's that you're killing me here.
So,
but when you're taking this stuff,
does it go down or do you have to like
deal with a hard dick for hours?
It's just on call but it's ready to
rock.
But when you wake up cars,
but when you wake up in the morning it's
like,
it's a lot of times it's like p plus
that.
It's like if you fuck a girl in the
morning with a p boner mixed with that
at the same time she's dead.
Oh poor girl.
Yeah.
Poor Lady.
What am I talking about?
This?
It's hilarious.
It's so weird that I do it though.
And it's only like if like if I'm with a
new girl,
I'd be like,
you know what?
I'm going to really impress her tonight
with this big snake venom.
Dick and roses is burnout.
Just that you don't want to set too to
higher standard.
What's embarrassing knows I collect them
and,
and it's,
it looks like a crazy person.
If you go in my car right now and if I
pulled out all the ones I had in my car,
it looks like a crazy,
crazy.
People will say,
if you didn't know me think I'm crazy.
Isn't that funny?
That's a funny thing people do.
You would think I was crazy if you've
paid attention to everything I do and
everything I said,
but if we could test him within a
reasonable financial range,
we should totally for cost a couple of
grand or something.
FDA though it really has gone through a
lot of it.
Most of it though,
it's been steroids.
Like a lot of them have had small
amounts of steroids in it.
And I was wondering when you were saying
that you hallucinated yeah,
it was a bath salts.
It dude.
I had to do a set,
I was in um,
in uh,
tempe Improv or no standup live in
Arizona.
I was,
I took some before then and I was with
Tony Hinchcliffe and I was telling Tony
was like,
man,
I don't know if I can go on stage.
Like I am seeing trails right now.
I had to go on stage like tripping and I
talked about it on stage.
Like I'm sorry if I'm crazy right now.
Like you guys are all like,
like swirls and stuff.
Like,
but that's how bad it was.
Like I can't see shit.
So that's when I kind of stopped my fun
hobby.
Damn Dude,
that's so dangerous.
He just rolling the dice that these
people in this gas station laboratory
are not going to kill you.
Yeah.
And what's crazy,
a couple of them are like,
I tried to find more information about
the companies that make it good luck.
They don't access shadow governments in
the Philippines.
Yeah.
Well this is my question.
Like they did have an ingredients.
Like is it say like you look at the
package,
it says what's in there?
No.
Well it does.
It does,
but you can tell it's not what it is.
It's say on the package.
Should have rented my car real quick and
get it.
A couple of kids.
I've got to go get one.
We're going to talk shit about you while
you're gone.
He's so ridiculous.
Do you know anybody else that takes
those things?
The only thing I've ever,
I've taken something,
not I boner pill,
but I remember taking a bumblebee or
black,
something like that,
but like I can stick a caffeine pill.
Oh,
okay.
I can go on stage or if me and my
friends,
we would take him like Jack ourselves up
before a concert and feel like we're
going to have a heart attack.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
it was probably like rip fuel,
like that kind of stuff.
The Federer or something like that.
It was bad for us too.
We knew those were horrible for you.
But see those things,
at least other people were taking them.
Who the fuck do you know?
Pioneer gas station,
boner pills and I'm going to do top,
they're like David Crockett.
He's setting a standard and he is
just such a ridiculous thing to want to
put in your body when the alternative
exists.
Like you could go to an actual doctor
and say,
I have a hard time getting an erection.
He'll prescribe you viagara.
We all know that doesn't kill you.
Maybe this is the weed of boner pills.
It's easy to get.
You can get it anywhere.
That's true.
It definitely is that you don't have to
go to a doctor.
Yeah,
that's what I mean by that.
Well,
it used to not have to go to doctors for
stuff.
You used to be able to get things
through Canadian pharmacies.
Canadian pharmacies would just send new
drugs.
It was like the big loophole.
How do people get,
you can get like that nuvigil stuff.
You can get free samples online or
something I've seen.
I don't know how you get up.
Yeah.
I don't know.
New vigils.
A little different or maybe one version
of it.
Provigil or Nuvigil.
I know for sure.
I've read guys st posting on message
boards saying that they bought that
stuff somewhere online.
I think it was the underground.
Yeah,
you can buy it from this like weird
India set us the new one.
Rhino too.
This is the one with the Hologram.
You're not gonna be able to probably
pick that up.
It's rhino 11 cause it's supposed to be
11 days at lasts 11 vulner real.
Yeah.
No it's not.
It comes in is we look at this capsule.
It comes in.
This is just for the pill.
It's like this weird matrix capsule.
Oh Dude.
How bad are these?
Meanwhile look at this.
It says this is hilarious.
It says platinum 6,000 like as if
there's some like measuring going on
like what's zero platinum?
4,000 yeah.
Come on.
Why are you pretending you have any
idea?
Is people making these just thrown some
shit in a bowl and mix it up while
they're drunk?
They're not.
They don't know what the fuck's in
there.
Platinum 6,000 fuck.
These are two companies too,
but that both use rhinos.
Why wouldn't you use Ryan when his
doctor Rhino and when is rhino 11?
Well,
Rhino is what those Asian people,
um,
believe that rhino horns give you a rank
reaction.
That's why they've killed so many
rhinos.
The reason why rhino horns or we're so
much,
and have you ever seen a Rhino Horn?
It doesn't even make any sense.
They're just gross.
It's like hair.
It's a giant hard like piece of
fingernail or hair.
Whereas like if you look at elephant
tusks,
you go,
well I kind of get it.
That's beautiful.
Those are,
those are amazing.
Rhino horns don't look cool.
They're gross looking at hill.
Yeah,
look at that.
And so they take those things and then
make some Chinese medicine.
That doesn't even work.
It doesn't even work.
I mean that doesn't make your dick hard.
It's,
we have viagara and they're still
killing rhinos.
So this actually has ingredients on it.
Like Chinese daughter seed,
asparagus.
There's a spare gas in here.
Asparagus.
Why would they put asparagus?
They want your penis smell different so
that you really feel like something's
happening.
That's true.
Or they just put asparagus to make it
go,
oh,
it's healthy.
It's got asparagus 10 and it has none of
that.
Maybe both arguments were brought up at
the meeting while they were cooking up.
Fuck it.
Best Bathtub Meth,
the Rhino 12 let's add some Kale.
The problem is,
man,
I don't want any fucking gangsters
coming out of us and trying to kill us
because we out what their products are.
You know,
because these products are not being
made by above board now folks,
most likely now,
and they constantly are changing their
names.
Like if you go through my collection of
these,
I don't know why I keep these,
but they're all different names.
There's not one.
That's what they have to.
Aubrey was telling us what happens.
This is what rb says I want.
I'm probably butchering it,
but Aubrey said that these people make
this stuff.
They put in Viagara,
which they buy from some Chinese
manufacturer.
They take that stuff.
What does,
what does it Modafinil,
is that what it's called?
Yeah.
Okay.
So they buy that stuff in bulk and then
they sell it for much more than it would
be if they sold it.
And like if you sell a prescription for
like a hundred pills be x amount of
dollars,
but if you can stuff it into two gas
station bullshit pills and sell each one
for 10 bucks,
like how much is a rhino to costs?
Well these new ones with the holograms
are like $14 but they last,
they do,
they don't last 11 days where they
definitely last a week.
But if that was dessert are only two
pills,
if that was a bottle of Viagra,
I mean $14 it wouldn't be two pills for
$14 it's where they probably make like
100% more and Viagra is bitch compared
to that.
This,
you know,
like this will beat the shit out of
Viagara cause this has like something
that makes it,
like Viagra is cool but it lasts a
couple hours.
It doesn't really do,
it just makes you have a boner kind of.
But this is like,
no,
you got bit by a snake boner for for
awhile.
Yeah,
I don't.
I would like to try it,
but it's not worth it and when it gets
you one of the best ones to do it,
I found that review of some of the
dangers that took rhinos seven Oh,
this one right here.
This is all that like breakdown of all
the different ingredients and whatnot of
it.
Oh,
put that shit up.
The main ingredient is called slide sill
that stilled naf believed in Nashville,
which is the active ingredient in
Viagra.
Oh,
okay.
Sold the Nafa,
all that stuff.
I would look at it.
It says right to,
yeah.
Why did I think it was modafinil?
Madame isn't modafinil or Nuvigil.
Okay.
That's it.
If you go up a little,
this is a serious side effects like
headache,
nausea and blurred vision.
I had that blurred vision part and
that's what made me stop these side
effects that generally appear when using
prescription ed medication.
It's funny too because yet the label
specifically makes the claim no
headache.
That's one of the primary complaints
about the supplement stuff that was in
it.
Okay.
I think her issues really make a lot of
sense.
I guess that's what it says was in it.
Yeah.
Well what about what he found was in it.
Okay,
well we'll,
we just read what it says.
Go Gee extract.
Dang.
Sen extract,
cinnamon bark,
blah,
blah.
Licorice.
Bunch of Bullshit Jensen.
Okay,
so what's actually in it?
That's really yet.
I mean then he,
I don't know,
he didn't test it himself.
Oh,
it goes up and then did research on all
those things and then did told you how
it worked for him.
Oh,
so did he say it worked?
Is Rhino seven work just said it's fast
acting.
You don't have to write back items
today.
Okay,
well there are things that,
okay.
One thing I can say is I was rock hard.
He says in all caps for like three days
on this stuff,
which is almost kind of annoying.
It depends on imagine having a hard on
when you have to do day to day tasks,
tucking your boner into your pants and
hoping it doesn't just pop out
unexpectedly.
Yeah.
Wow.
So these things really are,
but I see,
I thought you were going to send me
something where the guy actually tested
it to find out what the ingredients are.
That's what I'm interested in.
If you're gonna have fda.gov if you
could probably look up at like a couple
of these different ones.
I don't trust the government and their
line was Bob Chem trails.
The fucking line was about Dick Pills
definitely makes you a lot hornier like,
like horny.
I seek out massages.
I seek out like I like,
I literally like am a hundred percent
more hornier than when I'm on these
though.
Like almost bad almost back after you
take them like the next day.
Do you feel like shit?
No.
You feel worn out now.
There's no,
none of that kind of affects.
Like I don't get that spokesperson for
boner pills.
Oh,
I have a stake in these companies had an
addiction to them and I spinned out of
control with why don't they fucking
sponsor your podcast?
I don't want anything to do with them
anyway.
Can eat sponsors.
This should,
this should be your first sponsor.
I think on it needs to figure out what's
in these things and make their own.
I think anovos no,
probably not a good idea.
We know we don't want to be involved in
any shady shit.
Doctor,
doctor,
Brian's boner pills.
It's side on it company.
You could say I'm not really a doctor,
but I play one on the Internet.
It was fucking stethoscope on.
This is Dr. Ryan.
No,
I just about don't just hold onto a dead
Rhino's horn and actual we'll,
you know,
we can get that special effects guy,
that guy that did the American Werewolf
to make a rhino horn with blood at the
bottom of it.
Like you had just chopped it off like
that.
Oh like that?
Yeah.
And on the other side make it like a
helmet.
Like it looks like a Dick on the horn.
That'd be so offensive.
People would cry.
They killed a fucking
no,
just for their show.
Rhinos are beautiful man.
It is kind of fucked up that they get
killed for that one specific reason for
those horns.
So weird.
So it's just so weird.
But you know what?
That Rhino,
even though it looks sad that he got his
horns chopped off,
he's probably like,
did my face is a lot lighter now.
This is way better.
I don't even know.
He's an idiot.
Yeah.
Look at him.
It was stupid stupid eyelashes.
He doesn't know shit.
But did they chop his horn off to save
him?
Is that what they did here?
Because I know they're doing some weird
stuff to save.
What does it say?
So it just made foot boundary.
Oh,
farmed game.
Armed Gang.
Oh,
an armed gang reportedly broke into the
game preserve.
Oh,
and then cut the fucking horns off.
Stole seven rhino horns from a safe.
Oh,
so the photo doesn't represent,
does that photoshop maybe looks real
either way.
Um,
they're doing this to elephants.
They're painting their tusks pink.
They're dying.
The breast cases.
Yes.
For Awareness.
Talk for a second.
Like I write something down.
I've been forgetting and I just
remembered.
Oh my God.
Hold on one second.
The rhinos on these boner pills all have
their horns though.
So that's good.
There's weird that,
uh,
aunts and rhinoceroses both supposedly
can make boners.
What?
Yeah,
like ants.
Like if you grind up these African ants,
they can also make boners.
But Rhinoceros Horn doesn't work.
Maybe it does.
Maybe it does act.
There's so many rhinos,
oh,
hello.
Over these
side of that Chinese medicine stuff that
just doesn't do anything.
Some of it's got to work though.
I mean,
they were hitting mess back then when
they couldn't do testing that you had a
real,
you had a hope that you find a guy that
was completely legit.
A guy who really knew how to make magic
potions.
So essentially what it was when they
didn't have any data,
no internet,
no encyclopedias,
no fucking medical books to call upon
those,
those fucking people there.
There's a lot of guessing going on.
Not Real.
It's not real sack of online thing that
kind of went viral.
Oh.
But there's still some sort of
conservation effort going on,
but the pink tusk painting isn't a real
thing.
Okay,
so was it a photoshop thing or was it a
hoax?
Both.
The reports online regarding elephant
Tusk being painted pink and an effort to
do value the ivory poachers.
Well,
this man,
people would still take it.
They'd go,
dude is a pink one,
is one.
They tried to save site.
It's,
it is kind of fucked up,
man.
It's just,
it's just such a weird,
it's a weird thing that people would do
to chop off a part of an animal's face
to try to get their dick hard.
This is,
you know,
it'd be one thing if there wasn't an
alternative.
Don't you think?
If it was really awesome,
you would have heard about it though.
I don't know,
man.
I think I've,
I think it might be.
There might be something to it.
Okay.
Why don't you Google?
Can Rhino Horns really give you an
erection?
I just put Rhino Boehner and see what he
won't do it because it's his laptop.
I'm not getting on a list.
Not going to do this to me.
That can Rhino Horn other Stephen's show
you what?
That says,
Ken Rhino Horn.
Your cancer grow back regrow or what can
they be used for?
Well,
how about why you?
Why you doing that?
Erectile dysfunction.
That's what I'm looking for.
A band.
If it helped you with erectile
dysfunction and cancer,
why Agra and species protection?
Oh my God.
What was that saying?
It was speculative.
Yeah,
it's too small.
What does all speculation so far,
but the anti impotence,
drug,
Viagra,
blah,
blah.
This bigger penis is too,
I guess.
Huh?
Tiger Penis.
That's good.
Viagra,
cialis or powdered raggle.
Rhino Horn.
Which one is the most effective?
Click on that one.
Above top secret.
Definitely going to be legit.
If it's on above top secret,
especially if it's an a forum.
Black helicopters.
Is it possible in this day and age,
21st century.
There's still men out there that
honestly believe that powdered Horn of
an animal that has been butchered,
sometimes the arm,
blah,
um,
it has had its horn removed by a
chainsaw can still be effective.
Cure for rectal dysfunction.
Are we really still this backward?
Shouldn't the medical companies that are
the marketing meds that are marketing
meds,
which are supposed to be temporary
curious for this problem,
be targeting the men?
Mainly Oriental,
Asian racist.
Wow.
I'm sure who are directly responsible
for the death of so many rhino or I
know,
isn't it the way to say it or rhinos,
but it sounds better.
Like you're a sophisticated,
like dear so many Rhino Octopi.
I'm a fan of OCTOPI.
Uh,
I thought that most Far Eastern
countries were actually quite
progressive,
but they themselves are proving that
they are not exclamation point.
First of all,
fuck phase.
There's a billion people in China alone,
one yen.
There's not that many people chopping
off rhino horns.
If you compare them to the idiots that
we have here in America,
just by capita.
You know the,
a number of people that are scarfing of
Rhino Horn in Asia versus the number of
people here,
they're chewing on bath salts is
probably way more bass.
All people here than Rhino Horn people.
They're like,
that's a totally racist thing to say,
sir.
For someone who is so concerned with the
health and welfare of these Rhina Sy,
this guy's an idiot.
Yeah,
well,
he's a guy on a forum.
It's easy to be an idiot on a forum.
It's easily been in India on a podcast
too.
It's easy to be an idiot,
you know?
But I just,
I don't understand why.
Like there's,
there seems to be like an easy cure for
that.
Like if you just got them some of that
gas station,
boner pills,
they wouldn't want to have anything to
do with a rhino horn.
The Rhino Horn is worth thousands of
fucking,
yeah,
no.
Unless there is a little bit of Rhino
Horn in all these imagined calling us.
They even made a Hologram on this one.
Yeah,
no shit.
Imagine if that's what it is.
Yeah.
We kind of find out,
man.
I bet we would be the pioneer.
I'd be be the first person to actually
do a scientific test on these pills,
including the people that made them.
I bet they never tested shit.
They don't know what the fuck's in
there.
Probably,
you know,
when we had some of the earlier versions
of Alpha brain,
we would run these random tests on them
and we'd find out that like there would
be like b12 in air or something like
that or creating or it wasn't creating,
it was a beat 12 I would have to ask
Aubrey,
I'm talking about my ass,
but the bottom line was the mixers that
they used for our stuff,
when,
when they combine all of our stuff,
they didn't clean it out,
so they had whatever was in there
before.
Even though those just trace a trace
amount,
they don't give a fuck.
They just don't
shake that bag.
Talk Fart,
get on the radio,
maybe spit in there.
People are assholes.
Yeah.
It's probably done in a tent also.
You know,
like it's it,
it makes pride now the lab,
it's probably a tent somewhere.
Where do you think they make boner pills
if you had a Pomona?
Yeah,
this is definitely,
this is fan.
Nice material.
And I'll take this.
Some dudes,
they have a trailer right outside the
freeway,
like under an underpass.
They're cooking it right in plain sight.
Right.
I just want to know the guys that sell
these that come in to the gas stations.
Like what those guys like the salesman
that boner pills,
no,
number 11 and the sunglasses on all the
time.
You don't get to see their eyes sketchy
la looking left and looking right.
Apparently there's a big NPR piece on
this.
The other NBR people are in the getting
hard ons.
Nice.
I'm just looking down the whole article
right now,
but it says contrary to the popular myth
and the West Rhino Horn was never
traditionally viewed as an aphrodisiac.
I'm finding some stuff.
They use it for all sorts of things like
as a gift that some people think it's a
hangover
cure is valued more than gold.
Uh,
something like $1,400 an ounce.
Paris and gold.
Is that what you're talking about?
Yeah,
more than gold.
Yeah.
I'll show you.
There
is appetite for Rhino Horn drives
poaching in Africa.
This is from 2013.
Um,
they killed 668 rhinos in 2012.
I go on and talk about what they're
using to kill them and whatnot.
And then it says how much it's worth.
Look at this smuggler.
The guy give his name sits behind Rhino
Horn.
See?
Oh,
they were seized at the airport?
Yeah.
Wow.
There's a 60 pounds 60 pounds got caught
being smuggled in Ho Chi Minh City.
That was worth over like one point $5
million.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
They use it for a lot of things.
Apparently.
That is a crazy number.
I had no idea that six pounds worth 1
million bucks.
Okay.
Surveys,
30 different ailments including
hangovers like a fad.
It became popular,
but blah,
blah ass thing to do.
It's gift.
It's a great gift to your boss or
government official.
A guy.
It's a great gift for your boss or a
government official.
That's how boy,
Fan and bull,
how do you say that name?
Fan.
Retired Tom Dawn as we think we retired
official who used to approve
construction projects in the Vietnamese
government.
Got his stash of Rhino Horn.
He began taking Rhino Horn to recover
from drinking binges with contractors.
Every time I drank alcohol,
I'd go home and grind the horn and
drink.
It says,
boy,
a 65 year old grandfather of two an hour
later,
I'd throw up and feel sober again.
Hmm hmm.
That chick lake city has breakfast
table.
He unwraps piece of newspaper to reveal
small grade block of Rhino Horn.
He received as a gift.
Whoa boy.
Paul pours water into a specially made
bowl with a rough bottom and grinds the
block of Horn into a milky white liquid.
The grinding creates an odor that smells
like burned hair.
It's because Rhino Horn contains
Keratin,
the main component,
fingernails and hair.
He says that the value of Rhino Horn
grew as the value of Rhino Horn grew.
It became a kind of currency.
Oh,
it's fucked.
It's a part of their culture that's
fucked.
That's fucked it.
They're like trading in,
giving it to officials and bosses,
and they'll could I have her yo.
Very illegal.
Right?
Why don't we just like liquor that way?
Sometimes people use it.
How about Cuban cigars too?
Yeah.
Well,
Cuban cigars were the thing because
Cuban cigars up until really recently,
were illegal.
We could smoke one right now and it was
one.
Which three of them.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Who brought these in?
A real Cubans
there.
Three of them.
Cohibas hits man.
Goddammit.
Who brought him to us?
I'll remember.
No,
it was or someone within the last month
I feel like.
Was it Chris Ryan?
No,
Chris Ryan's on the new Nikki glaser
show.
Uh,
powerful.
Pretty funny on that.
That's a Chris Mcguire is the evp of
that show.
Such a good show.
Powerful Chris Mcguire.
We're here smoking a Cuban cigars.
You're allowed to smoke them now.
You don't what they say about Cuba,
man,
they say,
you got to get to Cuba now.
They'll like get there now because it's
going to turn into fucking applebee's.
It's going to be like,
oh,
giant.
Six months from now it'll be Marriott
bite the end off here.
I've read something about how like we
are already these dried out.
They're gonna.
They're going to be shitty.
I heard that were like taking all their
beverages,
like the Americans are already like
taking it.
Like other waters broke apart.
It broke apart.
It's dry.
We didn't put them in the human door.
I thought they were in these,
there's different kinds of these tubes
and some of these tubes are sealed.
These ones are just kind of screwed
down.
Let's say the Gar.
Okay.
People hear that silence.
That's a sound to me being a man smoking
a cigar.
Cuban by the way,
probably fake.
Just chewing on it.
It's not,
I don't chew on Dude,
we can get you sick.
I chewed tobacco when I was a kid cause
I read Tom Sawyer and huckleberry Finn,
which is now centered.
Okay.
Shoot you like on the side of your
mouth.
Yeah.
It's a real chew like you buy a brick of
it
will be and men here,
men one turn that um,
air conditioning thing on behind you
and we'll uh,
get some,
some hot flow up in this bitch
stuff.
Um,
but we were talking,
oh yeah.
So it was a a like a brick that looked
like maybe like a pack of gum or
something like that and you pull it
apart and then you bite into the brick
and pull off chunks of tobacco and chew
on it.
And I almost threw up once.
Maybe I did throw up,
but I was like,
all right,
this is stupid.
But I got into it because of Tom Sawyer
and huckleberry Finn.
Yeah.
I never got into smoking cigars because
I wanted in a hail it so much.
Yeah,
but you get high as fuck off these
things.
Tobacco has some sort of psychoactive
properties to it for sure.
And I think that they use it in a lot of
IOWASCA rituals with a,
they light tobacco smoke and they blow
it in your face while you're tripping.
And both Aubrey and Amber Lyon when they
did it,
we're talking about that.
It's definitely got some,
like I've smoked cigars before and got
some really good ideas where I was like,
well,
my brain is flying.
You'd probably really like cigarettes.
I just can't wait until,
except for the whole being healthy.
Yeah,
it probably would.
Yeah.
You know,
Eddie Bravo,
we'll smoke a cigarette every now and
then.
I remember that thing.
I found that thing a couple of weeks ago
that didn't want to bring up because I
wasn't sure if it was real,
but it said that cigarettes are like
proven.
There was some study that was proven to
give some sort of benefit for
creativity.
Yeah.
There was the negative of the inhaling
almost didn't even outweigh the benefit
you got from creativity.
Well health wise,
yeah,
the risk.
Yeah.
They were saying that it's like a
nootropic that it actually stimulates
brain function.
But if that's the case then you just
talking about the nicotine.
So,
um,
I've done before shows,
I've sucked on those blue cigarettes.
But first of all,
because I want to be Stephen Dorff
secretly and second of all,
because they do give you like a little
pep,
like a cup of coffee type pep,
you know?
Yeah.
Is that is,
but that's not as strong as its
cigarette
right now.
That shit's bullshit compared to a
cigarette like I've tried.
That's why I've tried doing like the
vape life and all that bullshit.
But it's just a,
it's not the same.
There's just something to,
I should smoke a cigarette before I go
onstage.
Yeah.
Let's see if it was just one time.
See what it's like.
You should also have it with your
morning coffee after you eat after sex.
You should have it with a drink while
you're driving.
The problem is
people get addicted,
you know,
I don't want,
I'm not going to do it.
Like I'm not going to get addicted to
cigarettes.
I,
I'll never let,
yeah,
the habit of doing it every time you had
a show and yeah,
that could be a problem.
Even if you only smoked two cigarettes a
weekend over the course of your life.
That's got,
that's a lot of cigarettes.
Yeah.
But you're old enough to do it now.
Well,
Eddie does.
That's the only reason why I would think
there'd be a way to do it is because
Eddie,
Eddie just,
we'll smoke a cigarette every now and
again.
Like he might smoke once a month or
every two months or something like that.
And I'm like,
wow,
and what does [inaudible] look at every
now and then?
Every now and then we'll have one.
Like,
that's interesting.
Diaz used to do that for a while too,
but he doesn't do it anymore.
He,
I think he still does the blu cigarette
though.
We're talking about Joey not native to
make our nick by the way,
but um,
dses to even after he quit,
he would go outside and take a cigarette
from you smoke one like right before a
show.
There's definitely some benefit in a
nicotine.
Definitely.
I just would,
I would wonder,
maybe I should just smoke a cigar before
I go on stage.
Like what gives you more of a rush?
I'd say cigarettes probably better
because you're inhaling it or you're
supposed to inhale it and it's faster.
You're not sticking up.
The place here that's a problem with is
tanking up the place.
First of all,
how dare I know.
I know.
I,
I'm one of the guys that,
that,
that when they smell this,
they get immediately angry.
They're like,
okay,
who's the guy that's just fucking ruined
everybody's Day?
This is what we're going to do.
We're going to go,
well,
old timey men,
not,
not like men.
The sixties and seventies were going to
go old timey like thirties and twenties
we're going to start smoking pipes.
Ooh,
no man,
man.
The only reason why I didn't want to
watch that show is because I read headed
grow,
the buzzing me redheaded girl was just
so hot.
Water wash them.
I like a girl's just not afraid to put
some pounds on tobacco.
You roll cigarettes with does that have
a lot of nicotine?
And I was just like,
oh yeah,
a spliff like if you made it half joint,
half those,
fuck you up,
man.
I'd never really do spliffs.
I'm not a spliff guy,
but when I was hanging out with Charlie
Murphy,
I did so Charlie Murphy would roll all
of them.
So you'd be taking in the weed with the
nicotine together.
I got higher than probably any other
time before in my life.
Doing shows with Charlie.
Charlie Murphy is one of the coolest
fucking guys in the world.
He really is.
I love that guy.
He's just such a good dude.
Such a solid guy and he smokes the shit
out of those blunts.
I hate what routes do that a lot of is
like the,
the blunts.
Usually it's,
I don't know why it's,
it's to me it's like a white guy smoking
a menthol.
Got,
Oh,
you're one of those blunt girls.
Great.
Well you dating girls that like the fuck
part guys.
Yeah,
totally normal.
Super Common.
I that's more of an age.
Did they say y'all a lot and get mad and
throw their hands around like gang
signs.
Like I could never be a cigar smoker in
my house because then you could tell
this with just fucking get on every
smells awesome.
You like the smell.
I love it.
Don't know what you're talking about,
but I don't love it as much as pipes.
And that's what I was thinking of.
Was it a Bertrand Russell,
I think who was a,
a a a famous inveterate pipe smoker.
Tobacco addict.
Brilliant man.
And back in the day,
um,
he wouldn't fly unless he could smoke on
the plane.
He wouldn't fly.
He said.
Yeah,
there is.
that's him.
He's got a story about a on tobacco.
Once you find,
find the youtube clip.
Okay.
Bertrand Russell on tobacco.
Fascinating guy,
because that guy lived in the dark ages
of information as far as the modern
world and the world of photography and
the ability to document things.
So to get a guy like this on a youtube
video shotos I see is like big tobacco.
What year was this?
You Bet.
Go patient by all day long.
The shipyard,
I need you most gp hasn't that shortens
your life?
Will they do to see your night fish took
to it?
I took two jumps 70 years ago.
Show that it doesn't seem to hit a vt
Greeky fake Shopha
pick.
Do you know Ryan?
What indication?
He saved my day
an airplane and did it getting
[inaudible].
I should get me a sheet and shocking,
but should I cannot smoke Geisha Day and
sure enough,
that was your neck.
She didn't do bad accident and all the
people in the back pain would drown
people in into smoking pot and jumped
into the Norwegian showed where we
landed.
Edward saved to the,
I owe my life to smoking.
Did you have,
did he drown?
All the people
playing crash,
crazy sacrifice that story.
He's a plane crash bro.
That's crazy.
So all the people that you see,
there's a real ashtray that somewhere
this seems like one of those stories
that everyone was like,
oh is that true?
But there was no internet back then so
we all just believed this guy.
I think there probably wouldn't have
been a plane accident,
you know?
And he probably made this shit up and
just cause he's old,
he's got a British accent or whatever,
like of liars got together and you know
the had like liar conventions.
Like the years that the internet came
out,
they'd be like,
boys,
we've got some problems.
We got some problems on the horizon.
We've got to figure out where to live
better.
This is how you got to cover your
tracks.
Like liars.
They used to be super common to be
completely full of Shit,
particularly about your martial arts
background.
There was a lot of really crazy people
when I was a kid that will like claim in
martial arts master and they would walk
around with like Chinese Kung Fu outfits
on and shit and slippers.
They're walk around with those Ninja
shoes where they had the toe that was
split.
You ever seen those shoes?
I've seen dudes walk around with Kung Fu
outfits and did represent two completely
different countries.
The Kung Fu outfit is from Japan.
The Ninjas slippers or from Japan?
They,
the Kung Fu output is from China rather
than Ninja outfit is from Japan.
These motherfuckers would mix and match
the different styles of train killer.
That guy isn't a good example though.
Like how back then you'd be like,
so every single person died in the
nonsmoking like every single one,
every like there was a line where it
said no smoking.
All those people died.
Well,
the front of the plane,
we'll all see you
think of when you're watching a guy like
Bertrand Russell.
How what?
When did,
when was that film did say if he was
talking about how it saved his life,
that had to be before they made that
shitty ass old grainy movie,
which was in black and white.
So it was probably a long fucking time
ago when planes were made out of fucking
gum wrappers is when he died.
That's when that interview was.
Okay,
so if it's in 59 then the plane was
probably from the forties or fifties I
mean,
who knows when that happened,
but yeah,
that ain't
good.
That's just mad denial and wanting an
excuse for smoking.
Yeah.
I say my live,
I smokes a pipe.
Dope pipe is definitely a different
animal.
Like my grandfather used to smoke and he
used to have those big,
back in the day they used to have,
there's big lighters that would sit on
your desk and it was just like,
oh yeah,
huge cloth wrap around the bottom of it.
Yeah,
I remember those.
This is the incident he was in.
Oh,
it was real.
In bursts.
Disaster it a crash for flying boat of
what?
A what?
A flying boat house.
Why didn't you mentioned that Birch
flying bus survivors.
We're all in the smoking compartment at
the back of the cabin.
It's true.
Damn.
Among the survivors.
Will the philosopher,
Bertrand Russell,
wikipedia citation needed look a fee we
could puffy da's.
Awesome.
Although it does say I'm five,
nine and brian cows,
my brother,
I don't know why.
Maybe he added that Brian?
No,
I think as in my,
um,
one of the things,
oh,
a shiny yet.
Nope,
not shiny.
Happy Jihad.
I'm going to be dead someday.
The sketch that Brian Count and I did in
my parents' basement where we're banging
each other,
we're working out,
we're getting pumped.
I think what,
how that whole thing started is because
you used to say he's your brother from
another mother and some idiot was like,
oh,
they're brothers.
Well maybe it's just for fun.
And people did any,
looks like my brother,
he totally looks like he'd be my
brother.
Like we just grew in different
directions.
He went north and south and I went east
and West
can be stretched his face out and he
stretched his shoulders out.
It's,
it's very similar in a lot of ways,
but he's um,
might as well be my brother.
But uh,
yeah,
wikipedia is wrong about a lot of shit.
It says I have crones disease to at
least it used to,
which I don't word that even start for
him.
That's funny.
I'm going to be in funny,
so I'm being silly.
I didn't want to change any of it.
I think it's funny.
I like what the Internet does for the
most part.
I think a little bit of disinformation
makes a little p.
People go,
what?
Wait,
are you serious?
I like that.
Like even when those stupid stories come
out,
like I killed them out in line with a
belt.
My own sister called me up,
my own fucking sisters.
Like,
was that true?
I go,
what are you talking about?
You can't kill a mountain line with a
bell like you don't.
You don't think I'd call you?
If I did,
I'd be like,
strap yourself in sister.
Cause your brother's a fucking
killed him.
Outline with a pal.
Oh my God.
What a fucking mount mine with a belt.
I'm about to go do a news story.
I'll call you back with it.
It'd be strutting around in my underwear
with scars all over my body.
I'd have all the gauze like with the
blood oozing through all the stitches,
which I would be fucking covered with.
Cause even if you survive a mountain
lion attack,
you need to fire then unscathed.
If you go to guy's code on Instagram,
guys code on Instagram is an excellent,
a little instagram page that has a lot
of pictures of girls butts.
Oh um,
but the great butts,
like you look at their assets and go,
good Lord,
why is it so appealing to look at?
You know,
even if someone knows he's never going
to get near that girl,
Ma much less be able to squeeze it from
behind.
Did you want to?
And so it's worth looking at like it
gives you that little ooh.
So they're providing you with a little
pleasure when they show you their acids
and those pictures,
those,
those wonderful gals of the instagram.
But I'm guys code had this picture of
this guy who was like in the 18 hundreds
killed a leopard with his bare hands.
He got attacked by a leopard in Africa
and it wasn't a giant one,
but it was big enough to fuck you up
man.
And he was all wrapped up and stitches,
but the thing was dead next to him and
his arms in a slang.
I mean,
he's fucked up.
And when you got fucked up back then you
got fucked up for keeps like they didn't
fix it.
There was no stem cells.
They didn't have acl surgery.
I mean I would literally be crippled.
Both of my knees would be completely
shot cause I had,
there's the guy,
what's his name?
Carl Eight Glee,
a k e.
L.
E.
Y.
And they have them down there as bad ass
of the week and it's got a leopard.
That shit.
How much you think that weighs?
I don't know,
but it's like 60 pounds.
Get enough to seem like it could be a
little bit dangerous,
but it also,
it looks like you could kind of kill
that.
It just would suck.
Like I have to pray to his poor cats
snack Mahmood.
That thing would kill you.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Are you kidding me?
Just think of,
I think he'd probably kill me.
I mean,
I think that guy probably got real
lucky.
The cat was probably sick,
which is why I was trying to attack and
kill a person the first place.
I mean that that does happen.
They get sick,
they get old,
they,
uh,
sometimes their teeth get worn out and
they can't kill something big anymore.
So that's one of the problems with
certain animals.
When they,
their predators,
they start picking on people because
they can't get animals anymore and
people are so goddamn slow.
So what'd he say?
I felt no pain,
but I certainly never thought for a
moment that I would come out alive.
I was rather calm as a matter of fact,
except for a tremendous and wildly
pleasant thrill.
I felt knowing that I was battling for
my life.
What a fucking man.
What a man.
That's why he survived.
What year was this?
What does it say it say?
It doesn't say what a fucking
1864 64 and an eight.
Oh,
he fought an elephant to,
he got pinned by an elephant.
Okay.
It might be a dick.
Yeah,
it's probably got slammed on the animal
side.
The fucking crocodile hunter overs day.
Just threatening animals.
Or you might,
you know,
if you're in Africa for a long enough
time,
you probably get jacked.
So he was born in 1865.
So how old do you think it wasn't?
That picture would probably 30 right?
Yeah.
Scroll up,
Jamie.
Let me get a look at them
all the way up.
There you go.
They're,
it's like Kyle Kinane.
Yeah,
that's a hard drinking.
35 that's the pens that lap that Lebron
would fuck you up with.
Fuck me up.
If we had it in the studio,
you know,
terrified.
We'd be,
oh,
it'd be terrified.
But then once you grab it,
you seem like you could just like fall
on its head out of your mind.
You're out of your mind.
If you ever held on to a cat,
the ones that get away,
you have,
you have cats deck.
You ever wash your cat?
Yeah.
I know.
They tried to kick and fucking twist and
they get mad at you.
Pure muscle.
You know I have two of the sweetest cats
in the world until you try to give them
a bath,
those little fuckers want to go to war
with you.
I'm like,
settle down.
We're just getting wet.
Right?
Settle down.
Wash yourself,
bitch.
You got a dirty ass.
Especially when they're fluffy.
Fluffy cats come out of the litter box
where the eco hanging off their asshole.
This is,
they can't clean it.
It's not supposed to exist in nature.
He never supposed to have an asshole
with all these feathers all around it.
They can catch shit.
What do you got there,
Jamie for us?
See his,
the Ackley or hour,
he say his last name,
Hall of African Mammals in the American
Museum of Natural History in Manhattan
is upper west side.
So what was he,
was he,
he was like some sort of conservation as
hunter back in the time of like
Roosevelt,
I'm looking through this article.
There's another guy,
it seems like he was head to head with
sort of like a Tesla Edison thing.
There's guy named award.
So they were going around searching and
hunting for animals and finding new
species of things and different in the
Congo.
Oh
Wow.
Sorts of different places like that.
I was watching this program on Buffalo,
um,
last night and uh,
they were talking about how the buffalo
were decimated and how,
um,
they were shipping these truckloads or a
trains train carriage is filled with
buffalo meat back to the east coast.
Buffalo meat became high in demand and
then buffalo hides were high in demand
and they were showing in this,
this thing that I was watching stacks of
skins just stacks of skins and of
skulls.
And you just look at her like,
what the F,
how did you do this?
How did you guys not think that this was
a terrible idea?
Look at that.
We get those stacks of skulls.
This is stacks that go all the way up to
the top of that railroad cart.
I mean,
that's fucking bananas.
Stacks of skins.
Look at these skins.
I mean,
they would just wiping out hundreds of
thousands of them.
Like how many did they wipe out a year?
Because you got to assume like that
stuff is probably recently come off the
animal that says it's 40,000 buffalo
hides right there.
Oh my God,
it's so crazy what they did.
They're going to get this guy on the
podcast.
His name's Dan Flores and I found out
about them from Steve Rinella and he has
a very interesting hypothesis or,
well,
he's a scientist so,
um,
he has an a and a historian I believe as
well.
So he has maybe not a scientist either
way.
His take on what happened with the
buffalo is essentially my butcher,
this,
but that when the first Europeans came
to North America,
they didn't find evidence of Buffalo.
They talked about everything else.
He talked about bear,
they talked about deer,
they talked about elk,
they talked about all these different
animals that we know exist here,
but they didn't really talk about
buffalo and the,
he believes that with the sheer numbers
of buffalo that that existed a hundred
years later.
It seems highly improbable that they
wouldn't talk about him.
And his take is that what happened was
when Europeans started showing up in
America,
they brought with them a lot of diseases
and those diseases that they gave these
people these like first of all,
like there's a,
there's a common myth apparently that
they gave them syphilis in the form of
scabs in blankets and they put scabs and
blankets and game to the native
Americans.
As far as I know that's not true.
Not only that,
they didn't know about bacteria then.
They didn't know what that you know that
you would,
that's how it was spread.
They didn't know that you would give
someone a scab and that the actual
tissue from the scab would cause the
disease.
The knowledge of like how diseases were
spread was not that sophisticated back
then as far as what I read.
But what he's saying is that when the
Europeans came here and they introduced
these new diseases that they had,
that the natives didn't have any immune
systems for,
it fucking devastated the population and
he said that that is responsible for as
many deaths as anything else to the
native Americans that lived here.
They just got fucking completely wiped
out by European diseases.
When that happened,
the native Americans were responsible
for keeping the buffalo populations and
check and had been doing so pretty
efficiently.
Ever since that the horse was brought to
North America because before the
Europeans came here,
native Americans didn't have horses.
They were on horses.
So the horses that,
you know,
we depict the wild west,
that native Americans rider on the horse
and how they've always been,
no,
no.
They were always like,
you know,
like really nomadic people that live in
Brazil or something like that in the
rain forest or Ecuador or something like
that.
They weren't on horses.
So they got the horses from the North
Americans,
but they also got the diseases and while
they hand the horses,
they were on the way to,
in his words,
extra painting the buffalo from their
domain,
which means it local extinction.
So they were already doing such an
efficient job of killing the buffalo
from horses because they'd run up on
horses and just fucking Arrow the shit
out of these buffalo.
And they were ruthlessly effective cause
they were on a horse.
So they could get that horse right up at
the buffalo because of Buffalo's full
clip is about 40 miles an hour.
But a horse can run about 50,
60,
you know,
and especially like a really strong
wars.
So these guys would just run up on these
fucking herds of buffalo and blast them
with arrows and kill them.
And then they got guns and once they got
guns,
good googly Mowgli between horses and
rifles.
I mean they were fucking these buffalo
up.
So what happened was they got almost
wiped out and the buffalo came back
strong.
So when they saw these millions of
buffalo out on these,
these prairies,
that was an over abundance,
that was a rare cycle in time that
corresponded with the death of the
native Americans.
And this is his,
um,
his paper that he wrote,
Buffalo Ecology,
I think something something Buffalo
ecologies name is Dan Flores.
See if we could find it.
I think it's one of those university
papers though,
that you probably have to have a some
sort of a membership and it's like one
of those things that that kid got in
trouble for releasing for free or that
kid that wound up killing himself.
Yeah,
pdf or you can get others a pdf,
what does it say?
Bison and bison diplomacy.
That's it.
The southern plains from 1800 to 1850
really,
really interesting stuff because you
know,
we're finding out more and more about
the history of this country obviously
because we still have Columbus Day.
I mean the fact that we still have a day
named after guy who didn't even get
here.
You know he landed in the West indies,
right?
Isn't that where he landed in The
Bahamas or some shit?
Whether things do you think are on the
way out and Columbus Day is definitely
on the way.
It should have been out a long time.
He's a murderer.
What else?
Columbus as a mass murderer.
If you go to collage to the,
there was a missionary or someone that
was there at the time of Columbus that
detailed the horrors of what they did to
the native American people that they
found,
which to try to get these people to give
them gold.
I mean the fucking whores.
They would cut off body parts and send
these people out.
They would cut their arms off if they
didn't bring back a certain amount of
weight and gold,
they would smash babies on the rocks.
They would take their children from them
and smash them in the rocks.
We were talking about boat boats filled
with serial killers and we have,
we have a holiday or kids get off school
for a guy who ran a boat of serial
killers that came across the ocean and
just laid waste to everybody in front of
them.
I'm from a city that's named after him,
Columbus.
We even have his boat,
like a recreation of his boat in
Columbus,
Ohio.
Fucking crazy,
man.
Where's that?
A lighter brother.
He's got it said,
you know,
sparked that backups.
Yeah,
I'm high as fuck office.
The wheat,
the wheat helps.
But um,
uh,
I dunno how we got on this bisons I was
watching the buffalo blah,
blah blah.
We're talking about Dick's and it just
went from Rhinos to oh yeah.
That dude,
um,
that I posted yesterday was at cjw
underscore photography.
That guy's a instagram page.
He got ahold of me and he's making that
wolf the wolf with the snow.
He's going to put down a steel plate and
send it to us.
We're going to put it up here.
Oh,
so most metal prints of bad ass.
Yeah.
And that was like one of the most dope
nature photographs ever.
Have you seen it Brian?
Pull it up.
It's a,
on my instagram page is the one that was
specific.
It's got this wolf and his face is
covered in snow and he's looking at you,
not the one that we showed John Dudley,
my friend John who on here yesterday.
Dude.
He fought a pack of wolves off.
It was trying to take his elk.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Barefoot.
Like what do you do to two guides to
barefoot only as asshole.
That's it's how do we find them?
How has his feet,
he was in Alberta,
he shot an elk in these wolves,
started circling and they ran in and
they were trying to scare him off the
elk and he shot one and then the other
wolves showed up and he started howling
and circling them that fucking picture.
It's how dope is that picture.
God Damn.
I want to,
he's going to come to the shows,
one of the shows at the fillmore in San
Francisco and a,
I want to talk to them and find out how
he took this and where was he got to be
created.
It's got to take lots of hours
of sitting and waiting and camping and
being really cold.
Yeah.
And to get this perfect shot.
God,
what a cool animal.
Hmm.
I bet he's got some crazy stories of
getting them,
uh,
and just being surrounded by wolves and
whatnot because he's got a lot of cool
pictures.
Yeah.
You gotta be,
you gotta put yourself in a weird spot
to be a bold motherfucker to get that
photo.
I mean,
cause you can only be so far away,
right?
Yeah.
Your lenses can only take you.
So
like how,
how close would you be able to like
that's so
it could be cried so it could be a
little bit off,
but it's such a really close picture.
I bet he had a really good like 400 to
600 Lens,
so,
oh my God.
Maybe 50 to 100 yards at the Oregon Zoo.
A hundred yards.
Yeah,
I doubt it.
But like 50 yards.
Yeah.
It's hard.
I would imagine he'd be close to the
ground.
I'm just going to be crazy.
It depends what camera you use to.
Um,
if you go to see it,
go to his,
um,
his instagram,
there's a picture of that wolf with
another wolf there.
That's sweet.
Yeah.
He's got a pawnshop hopcat.
Dope Shit.
Yeah,
that's a bobcat.
I think we're links one of those.
Sweet,
well those mountain lions,
it's got to look at that one.
Licking his lips is a gene Simmons
mountain mine make it up.
What do you think about Gene Simmons and
that whole controversy about what
controversial am calling out Nwa saying
they shouldn't be allowed in the rock
and roll hall of fame because he said
that rock and roll.
Um,
well kiss wasn't in the rock and roll
hall of fame forever.
So if I was him,
I'd be like,
fuck the rock and roll hall of fame.
Fame is more of like a pop pop music,
popular Music Hall of fame.
There's a goal.
That shit down the pharmacy.
That wolf.
Yeah.
Um,
the beastie boys are kind of rock
though.
If you listen to Paul's Boutique,
that's the end.
That's it.
We'll scroll up then.
Paul's Boutique Dude is,
is a rock and roll album or an,
I mean,
I don't know what,
how is that it?
Oh No,
maybe he's got another page.
No,
man.
That's it.
Okay.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
He's got 353 posts.
That's not at Jamie refreshing.
It doesn't say no.
It's just not refreshing.
Just refresh it.
Oh,
there it goes.
looking at raccoon.
That's great.
Erections are not,
yeah,
he's got great photos.
Oh,
amazing.
Man.
No,
that's not at Jamie.
There's,
there's one scroll down to the exact
same pose that wolf,
but he's with another wolf.
Why?
Oh,
there it goes.
It's weird how it loads.
Right.
And then it's not loading up though.
God Damn instagram.
You know what it is?
They went up to 62nd videos and their
shit's getting hammered.
Yeah.
Hammer time.
Um,
there's another thing that I posted.
There it is right there.
There's another thing that I posted that
is the exact same wolf,
but with another wolf next to him.
That might even be more bad ass.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah.
That's way better.
Oh my God.
It's like the wolf's telling him like,
let's go kill that photography.
Hey Dude,
if you're,
if you're listening,
uh,
scratch that.
Make me one of these,
make me the double wolf.
Fuck.
That's amazing.
God.
Damn,
that's crazy.
Holy Shit.
What a picture that guy deserves like an
award for that picture.
Like that might be,
I'm going to say it is.
That's the coolest wildlife photograph
I've ever seen.
Wow.
That's cool.
Because yeah,
it was undeniably cool that the photo
looks so rare with,
I mean,
how do you get a wolf with all that snow
all over his face like that.
What are the odds you're gonna capture
that.
And then another one,
the same size right next to him.
Maybe his wife.
The wife won't pay the Wolfson.
I left as a wife.
Who is the wife?
The wife's on there.
Right?
Cause it looks like he's,
she's a bitch.
She's bitching at him.
Yeah.
You don't mind the fact that he only
killed five elk.
You sell fucking lazy when you were
younger.
When you first met me,
you did sound much to impress me
because a guy's a,
an animal to get out there.
Chris,
you're a fucking animal.
Uh,
just uh,
I mean that's a Timberwolf.
Yeah,
man.
I think that's a yellowstone.
She's this,
that those are in yellow.
They have a lot of them in yellowstone.
It's crazy.
There's,
um,
there's a cool video that I posted or a
photo I posted today from a national
geographic.
The National Geographic instagram page
is another one I'm fucking completely
addicted to every other day.
They have some just whoa photo where you
look and you go,
fuck God dammit,
and today was a,
these two bears there were duking it out
in yellowstone.
Look at the size of these fucking
beasts.
Look at a clause on him,
the closet or on that one's back as
their fight is two giant ass fucking
grizzlies are going at it and one of
them has wolverine style razor blades
coming out of his front arm.
Fuck man.
Another John Dudley story.
John who was here yesterday,
he saw a bear kill a moose.
He was there when a grizzly swatted a
moose in the back and broke it's back.
Wow.
He said the bear was chasing the Mousse.
It got the,
they got into conflict.
The bear got on top of him and swatted
is back and broke it.
He said he broke his back with one
swipe.
Wow.
He also talked about this cabin that
they had in the woods where this bare
broken in the cabin,
pulled the wall apart,
pulled the doorframe and the door off
the wall with these nine inch spike
nails all around it.
Then there was a stove inside that
smelled like food.
He crushed the stove to the ground like
you would stomp on a soda can just to
ooze out whatever,
like fat and grease was inside the
stove.
Fuck bears man.
Fuck that.
So crazy that we want more of those are
like,
we need to save those when you need them
everywhere and the wolves to were like,
oh,
and they're,
they're so awesome.
Keeping that things a killing machine
looking right through your eyes.
It's cool that they exist though,
you know?
I mean it would be kind of cool of
dinosaurs were still rare here too.
If there was like a real Jurassic
island,
you know,
suck.
Come on man.
Long as you didn't have to go there.
If it was like an island like New
Zealand.
Yeah,
yeah.
The Middle Past Hawaii,
Guam.
Yeah.
Well New Zealand is huge.
Probably not New Zealand.
We would want to do that to those two.
Yeah,
they can get too big.
Well,
they don't have a New Zealand.
It was like crazy wildlife situation
because New Zealand is a fairly recent
continent or island as far as I know,
as far as like the volcano volcanic
activity of the earth.
And it wasn't a lot of land masses
connecting it to other places.
So they have some indigenous wildlife,
like a bunch of weird animals and shit,
but they also have a lot of stuff that
is non native that was brought in.
Like all these a hunting animals.
These,
these really rich dudes a long time ago,
basically turn New Zealand into a
hunting preserve and they just let these
stags loose.
These European dear,
um,
these red deer and stags tags is like,
uh,
a European form of elk and a,
they let all these things loose all
throughout New Zealand,
but they don't have any mountain lions.
They don't want any bobcat's.
They don't have wolves,
enough coyotes that,
of anything that kills these things.
So they have to send people out there to
kill him.
Like people just killing them
constantly.
And when some of the populations of some
of the animals get too high,
they have to fly over him and fucking
gun him down from the sky.
They're having this problem right now
with Cat Island,
which is that island of cats,
Alpha Japan and there are the,
and they're in breeding like crazy.
It's scary.
All these cats like thousands and
thousands of cats just live on this
island must smell like shit by the way,
I suppose.
Smells like ammonia pissed,
you know.
Did you see what's going on with
Fukushima?
Fukushima has a problem with radioactive
wild boars.
Nice.
There's like hundreds of radioactive
wild boars that have taken over that
area because you know,
the people aren't really there anymore
and they're running rampant and they
have a problem with them.
They don't know what to do.
They have radioactive wild pigs.
Look at this fucking thing.
Thousands of,
oh,
I said hundreds.
Thousands of radioactive boars are
overrunning farmland in Fukushima.
But look at the photos of them.
They have some photos of these fucking
bores.
Um,
maybe different article.
Yeah.
Here's a good one.
That might be stock footage though.
Yeah.
Wild boar stock seat on the fucking
Internet wizard.
Dude.
I know it's probably all the photos are
probably stock,
but there was one video of this guy who
had like a radioactive suit on like he
was some sort of a scientist and these
bores were chasing him.
Yeah,
they all look stock,
but whatever.
Neha,
who the fuck's going to go there and
take those pictures?
What is this other radioactive dudes?
Those the a,
the board themselves,
they have a real problem.
Those things start turning into like
some comic book,
Superhero type character powers.
I mean they could things of radioactive,
like what if they start morphing?
What if it becomes super smart because
we already know that boards are smart.
Like pigs are supposed to be smarter
than dogs,
right?
Oh there they are.
This is the real ones.
Shit running down the street.
Lots of them slamming into the fucking
fence trying to get out of this cage and
they caught him in.
Good luck.
Japan,
they have,
by the way,
that that thing is still leaking
thousands of gallons of radioactive shit
into the water every day
isn't California.
And we still have that gas leak up and
send me valley or wherever that is.
Did they?
Yeah,
she'll that a long time ago,
but that was bad.
They said it was like every car in the
United States,
the emissions from every car in the
United States in one day.
Wow.
I might have made that number up.
FYI.
Powerful desk squad cop.
I liked this one man that I'm drinking
out of available right now at death
squad.
Dot TV.
Brian Red band creations.
Yeah.
That's fun stuff.
You,
uh,
you,
you remember when we used to talk about
that radioactive up there and,
and uh,
the thing I,
it's funny because I know somebody or I
met these triplets the other day that,
that grew up there.
What do you think the odds are that
they're triplets because they grew up
near that radioactive?
What makes triplets?
It's a real good question.
I think horse the horse,
you just have to love Dick so much that
you take in so much calm that there's
this calm just rushes and no one egg
wins.
Yeah.
Maybe a a dude who's just got a lot of
calm.
Maybe that's what makes me super
aggressive.
[inaudible] people that have triplets my
age.
But I think nowadays it's probably more
for like maybe they might be using
fertility thing or two,
what you take like an accident they had
three and the only one is right.
That definitely happens.
That happens with the older ladies.
That's like John and kate plus eight.
Remember that chicken like seven fucking
babies inside of her and when they know
eight inside of her and then two
additionally they had to first and
decided they wanted more and so they
fill themselves up with babies.
And uh,
I remember that show.
Boy that was an interesting show because
that was a show that kind of showed how
much pressure of the average person gets
under when you're under the microscope.
Like people that behave like totally
normal,
they think their behavior is totally
but then all of sudden they're under the
microscope and the whole world sees that
and then they get criticized and freaked
on and then next thing you know,
they can't handle it anymore and they
break up.
And then John,
you know,
was forced to get like regular jobs and
catch them dating women and it was,
you know,
they would let hound the guy.
I remember that.
Yeah.
It was really ugly.
As real ugly.
Okay.
And you know,
they're poor fucking kids,
man.
Yeah.
Almost.
Yes.
Just weird.
So I guess they had six.
Yeah.
And then they,
uh,
they had two previous than they had six
babies inside of her.
And that's all those fertility drugs for
sure.
That's a weird man.
It's weird,
you know,
because it's also weird because I'm
pretty sure they were strictly
religious,
weren't thing.
That's why I feel like that's when it
happens.
Yeah.
Well not really because see like God
says be fruitful and multiply,
but he doesn't say anything about taking
fertility drugs in order to make that
happen.
You know?
And if it's God's plan,
is it all God's plan when a scientist
steps in?
Is it God's plan?
Because a scientist is here that God
make the scientist,
you know,
where do you draw the line as far as
like what God wants because if that's
true,
um,
someone invented abortion.
Was it God's plan to make abortion?
It was God's plan for everything
and a multiple families for I'm from,
cause if like Catholic family raised
over 10 kids,
I know at least three families that have
10 12 kids.
Again,
horse horse.
Was it fertility pills or of no,
it's just like they almost had one every
year.
They just like to fuck constant job this
time.
Fuck you went to all boys.
One's all girls.
The kid.
10 of them.
Yeah.
Like 10 girls yet all blonde girls.
That's great.
Wow.
Lot of fucking going on 10 kids.
You know when you die,
how you like shoot yourself in the all
the pis and everything comes out if you
have any in you.
Right.
Well,
I mean surely there's something that you
have an anal sex with.
A girl likes to do meth.
Eddie Bravo.
He said that's the way to go because
they don't eat.
Ah,
Brian is a light bulb went off about the
math.
They don't eat and their apartments are
squeaky clean.
All they do is clean their apartments.
I was just thinking of how realistic
would it be,
you know that Jesus on the cross,
if it was realistic,
if it was just shit and piss everywhere
on the bottom of the cross and it cause
even though they probably definitely be
some,
I would imagine if they fed them before
they strung him up there.
It's interesting too because they always
show the crucifixion marks through the
hands,
but apparently that's not capable of
supporting your body.
They go through the wrist.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Cause that's how you hang a deer.
You go through the,
the ligament behind the knee and you put
like a stick through it and you get to
hang up.
No suffocation.
The way I would have hung his body.
He would have suffocated in a couple of
hours instead of days because the way
the honey,
yeah,
the way your body would have hung the
weight on your diaphragm or something
like that.
I was too much in Catholic religion
class to have all this stuff explained
it.
Now I've learned extra stuff.
No,
what uh,
you know,
there was a story that Danieli Bolelli
uh,
of history on fire.
He's got an awesome podcast history on
fire and the opening podcast.
He has a pilot like episode zero zero
and then he says episode one in episode
one,
he tells a story that he told on this
podcast about this.
Uh,
I believe it was the Romans had hung up
some insane,
like a hundred miles of bodies,
something crazy like that.
Like what was the,
the actual number I remember your till
is saying that right now it was like the
hymn sing.
Yeah.
It's a whole pathway or the whole road
to wherever it was a hundred miles or
whatever the fuck it was was just like
every x amount of meters.
They had a body that was crucified all,
all along the road.
The like that was how people used to
roll back then.
They used to scare the shit out of
people.
There was no like hiding the photos of
the caskets.
No,
they,
they hung people on sticks,
stuffed them into the ground.
Spartacus road,
6,000 spartacus,
6,000.
I think it's the same thing.
They crucified 6,000 people.
Jesus Christ.
People were Baroud back then.
I mean,
I guess they're brutal today.
Um,
there was an article that I tweeted
earlier today are retweeted that.
Um,
okay.
What's her name?
Jen briny.
How do you Sara last name?
Um,
she's the one who has that a political
podcast.
It's supposed to be good.
What is her name?
But anyway,
the,
the articles about a guy,
he,
she retweeted something from,
I think it was from the Guardian where a
guy wrote what it feels like to be a on
the drone kill list and that he made his
way into Europe specifically because he
was worried that they were going to kill
him with a drone.
And then he used to hide and sleep under
trees so that his family,
Eric,
Jen Briny,
how you spelled?
that this guy would,
would sleep under trees.
It was in the independent sleep under
trees to protect his family because no
one wanted to be near him because he was
on the fucking kill list for drones.
Wow.
You see that journey with a chainsaw?
That's scary.
They made a drone that has a chain store
attached to it and it's like doom.
Did you see the [inaudible] video?
I actually haven't seen it,
but I saw the billboard on sunset.
It's a movie or is it a video game?
There's a video,
but the,
the video,
the video looks insane,
but the,
the doom billboard makes me want to play
doom.
What is it?
Supply chain supplying chain saw drone.
They attach a chain saw to the bottom of
a drone,
turn it on and destroy it.
I think this is the video where they'd
destroy a snowmen with.
But how scary is that?
It's a matter of time before we have to
go to war with drones,
right?
Yeah.
Oh my God,
this is letters.
There's flying over and Jack and snow
man in the head cutting off,
icicles
released.
It's really popular.
That's doing some cool things.
It's like a Dji Phantom,
something France.
Him for it can follow you.
You just like tap it,
tap the screen and it'll follow you
around.
[inaudible] do you,
do you have to register drones?
Yeah.
Jeff.
And now,
now you do all of them?
Yeah.
Is it like this year I believe.
Oh Wow.
That's good.
All of those programs,
they have things built into them.
They won't,
they won't even let you fly into like
non fly zones.
Things cut,
cutting
limbs off trees and then there you have
another drone flying around taking video
of it,
which is hilarious.
What a weird world we're living in
today,
man.
I've thought about getting one just to
try it.
Do you told us you don't have one?
It seems right up your alley.
Yeah.
Pull up the drone.
I'm not the drone.
The doom footage show Bryan.
It doom.
Go full screen please and don't,
don't play a shit until it's ready.
Multiplier one,
right?
Yeah.
Dude.
Wait.
Do you see this?
The multiplayer looks so bad ass.
Yeah.
It's like quake three on crack.
I shouldn't say that on steroids from
Hell.
No.
Those hacks hangs from Cra on crack from
how watch this.
Look at this.
Look at the graphics.
First of all,
how wild is this?
Look,
this looks,
reminds me totally click right.
Totally.
Well it's in software.
It's the same guys.
All right.
Oh this looks so fun.
Should we brian,
should we get a land party in here?
Fuck yeah,
we should.
We should such it should be,
yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
What is the company that,
oh my God,
what is the company that we should,
uh,
by our pcs from a couple of them.
We get them Falcon or alien.
We should get alien ware cause alienware
used to sponsor us.
Yeah.
So just out of loyalty and respect,
we should get alienware.
So we'll should contact alienware and
let them know we're going to set up a
fucking land party up or you're going
deep on this.
I can tell.
We'll have some fun.
But I want to do though,
Brian is you and me do this and we'll go
on twitch.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
We just gotta be really pc sockets
that's shitting happening.
What are you talking about?
Take off your shirt as a guy on twitch
or you'll get banned.
Everybody that's on twitch who keep
their fucking shirt on.
How about that?
Except Demetrius Mighty Mouse Johnson
and I think John Dodson's on twitch to
[inaudible] James.
Now all those guys could take their
shirt off.
Everybody else.
Keep your fucking disgusting man.
Boobs away from my Chris Screen.
I've never seen this.
I have two pounds.
Well,
you're lying to.
Don't lie to me.
So alienware if you're listening and
hook us up or Falcon northwest,
do you want to bring us over?
Yeah,
I like alienware man.
I,
I had that old laptop that they gave us
back in the day and I will turn it on
the other day.
I'm pretty sure they both sponsored
fighters,
I'm pretty sure.
Did they?
Sure.
Yeah.
So are you,
I'm touting down with all but loyalty to
alienware for two reasons.
One,
because we used to use them.
I used to run the podcast,
uh,
my,
my version of it and you know,
when I used to research stuff that was
all from the alienware back then.
That was cool.
I liked it was big ass fucking screen.
Who did I give that to?
Okay.
Uh,
you remember I remembered you telling me
you gave it to somebody.
Somebody who plays games.
Don't care trainer,
didn't you?
You have to.
Justin was the,
Justin probably was justin.
I think you sold it.
They make bad ass laptop.
So I like,
I like how the ones that we had,
you could change all the colors of the
keywords.
So like half of it's purple,
half of it's blue.
Yeah Dude,
I'm infatuated with the Lenovo
thinkpads.
I read this review of a Lenovo thinkpad.
It has 15 hours of battery life that's
supposed to have them the most tactile
feeling keyboard.
Like this guy was,
di did a review of it and he said that
the keyboard itself I saved at home.
Second,
he said that the keyboard itself was so
good that it actually upped his words
per minute faster than his,
uh,
his average wedge,
which I was like,
what?
How is that even possible?
Yeah,
but it seems like bullshit.
Who does that?
What we say that Lenovo thinkpad t 50
review and it's on Laptop magazine.
I would do it except for the having to
deal with windows.
I'm just,
I'm top mag.com.
Yeah,
but I mean have you tried the newest
windows?
Like what is like windows,
what do we all know when those 10 for
real.
That's hilarious.
Um,
but it's supposed to keyboards supposed
to be amazing and the battery life's
supposed to be crazy.
I'm just bored.
I just want to try something else.
I know that apple and also you can take
the battery out.
You'd have a separate battery.
You remember when you could do that?
Yeah,
something like that.
I like the fact that you keep a fucking
full battery with you on that came up
that there,
that's their kind of pitch.
I think it's lg or slide in slide out
battery.
And it comes with the next one.
Well,
my galaxy until the recent one,
my Samsung Galaxy had that and it was
waterproof and you can take the battery
out.
It was still waterproof,
goddammit keys to be able to carry an
extra battery it in your laptop bag and
your,
your laptop was running out of battery.
Close it,
pop that bitch out,
pop the new end.
You're back in action.
Fully loaded.
But now you have those like portable
charger,
battery chargers and things like that.
So it's kind of unnecessary.
What's really interesting is as good,
oh yeah,
I have one that can charge up your a
iphone,
I think two or three times.
Your iphone.
Well,
what about your laptop?
Laptop,
that mean they have big battery pack.
So you've had one before.
But I had,
when I went hunting,
I brought one with me that I didn't even
want abusing cause it was so tired at
the end I was like,
I am going to document this like William
Shakespeare.
I'm going to be like hemingway out there
in the field.
Fuck that.
The end of the day,
you've walked 14 miles up mountains.
You're exhausted.
You don't want to do shit.
You take a shit in the woods,
dig a hole,
go back to your tent,
pass out.
But um,
I carried it around.
It was probably like at least 10 pounds.
It was huge,
but it worked.
Worked when you need it.
IPAD,
I'm sure.
No,
fuck I pads.
Yeah,
I like a button,
man.
I'm a,
I'm a tactile person.
I like to feel buttons.
Like even I,
it took me a long time to get used to
the iphone,
but the iphone is benefits of touching
the screen.
You know,
having the full screen real estate for
videos and photographs and email.
It's so worth it.
It's so worth it because I know that
blackberry came out with a new one with
a giant ass screen and then the,
the thing slides out the bottom and then
you have a keyboard,
not pioneer.
No enough is enough.
You could just get the ipad pro with a
keyboard,
like a real keyboard.
My snap.
You can't save files.
I can,
no,
you can't.
You can't like put like Microsoft word
files in a folder on your desktop.
Yeah,
they have Microsoft word now on your
desktop,
but you can put it in the cloud
equivalent thing.
You can nowadays it close to you.
What do you mean close to that?
Oh,
does it go in the cloud or is it uh,
uh,
it probably is saved on your ipad but I
bet you could use like the docs app for
Google or something like that.
Yeah.
Pages for that's on that and you can
save it on something.
So offline use,
it's cached and the new force speaker
system on the ipad pro is bad ass.
There's four different speakers and it
detects if you're holding it.
So like it,
if you're holding it on the left side it
will make a,
the bottom left louder,
you know to,
you know,
it knows where your hands are.
Tom Or whatever.
Use that though is in a hotel room.
In a hotel room.
I have one of those little bluetooth
speakers.
Those tubes.
It is so good.
Bad.
It sounds so good.
I bring that fucker with me to green
rooms now because I sometimes you're in
a green room and you'll listen to some
CNC music factory and shit.
Dat,
dat,
dat.
Come on.
I don't,
this is not what I want to hear.
When I get ready for a show,
I want to hear my shit.
It's like put on some cool music.
It's great man.
It's great having one was little things
because it's so small.
Why did they have,
has anyone ever asked you or have you
ever thought of like,
uh,
having your own playlist before you go
on?
I guess for the theater when people,
I don't want to infringe on the creative
rights of the guy.
Who's the sound guy in that situation
you just said,
right now you've got someone picking a C
and c music factory to warm up your
crowd like that.
I'm totally making that part up but it
can happen.
But no,
there've been some bad fucking music.
There've been some bad music way.
Where the fuck did you get CNC music
factors and that's a randomly allocating
something really shitty from a long time
ago.
That's hilarious.
I haven't thought about that.
I want to go,
I mean you could have like a nice little
like just even like if you just put it
in your warmup or your workout playlist
and just have those like rock songs with
a couple of a hip hop songs.
Like that'd be good to play for 30
minutes while someone's warming up
instead of a anything random love shack
or be 50 Tuesdays.
Yeah,
they do that a lot but sometimes they
get good songs.
Like there was a place where at the
other day in um,
Santa Barbara,
we did the Arlington Theater,
which was fucking awesome.
Hinchcliffe Diaz and I did this theater
in Santa Barbara is great fuck and I
loves it above.
That's my spot,
dude.
That is the spot and I want to talk
about it anymore.
I don't want to talk anymore.
I don't want anybody to know about it.
So it's such a nice city and how much
land you could get out there.
Also,
if you bring up just winning a little
gross from cattle.
Whoo.
Um,
but anyway,
my point being they had a,
they were playing some music.
I saved it on my shoulders,
lamb,
and it was,
uh,
it was some sort of,
um,
Spanish music,
like some Spanish rock that I'd never
heard of before and they're singing it
in Spanish.
I was like,
God damn,
this is awesome.
Like whatever it is.
I love it.
I don't remember what it was.
One direction.
No,
no.
Spark up my cute it.
Would you say Jamie was given another
shitty band?
It's called middle.
It says dj snake featuring bipolar
sunshine.
What's that even mean?
I don't know man.
I Dunno,
but uh,
see if you could find that.
I got it.
Listen to this.
We'll fuck us up.
That's fine.
It'll fuck us up on youtube.
50 million views on youtube.
Oh,
bipolar sunshine,
a snippet of it.
I can get it for the audio.
Okay.
For us,
for the audio listening.
Youtube people won't hear this part.
Okay.
Youtube people
should I sing along?
So it's like there's this,
is this definitely the one that I,
this is not sound like it.
How do you know what you've seen now
that ain't that Jamie,
oh,
this is it.
I'm sorry.
Try this.
Uh,
it is a l e,
g r e two zero zero three.
Yeah.
Alegria and then it's like a little
space.
Two zero zero three truby trio.
This is what it was.
Um,
that would,
that one was that I just,
um,
said was one that,
was it showed up at the front of Shizam
and I mistakenly thought it was the last
one that I shazammed is that a verb?
Shizam she's doing this now.
I fucking love Shizam that's such a
great application.
You know,
you don't even have to use it anymore.
You could just use Siri.
She doesn't know I'm done.
I'm like that bitch.
Yeah.
What?
Yeah,
this is it.
This definitely it.
Does this have any hits online?
So the youtube people hear this or no,
you don't even hear anything?
Youtube people for you,
like what is happening over there?
You're going to have to go to it.
It sounds like jumps not good,
dude.
It gets going,
but it's what I like about Spanish.
Music is a,
I don't know what the fuck they're
saying.
So it's cool.
Like I get the emotions and I get the
Vibe,
but it's rusted,
rusted root.
That sounds like your Dick.
Now after you bang a chick was on the
period.
Oh God,
no.
I have so big
an 18 inch root.
Keep this going.
If the youtube people don't hear it,
do you think it will get us pulled off
itunes?
That won't happen,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
but Joey Diaz,
his cousin has a ban from Cuba.
It's awesome.
That is.
They're fucking amazing.
And they're on my playlist here.
Oh really?
Yeah.
With Alfonso X.
X.
Alfonso X.
It's x a.
There are fucking bat.
What is that?
That's the thing.
That was the route that was poured out
of a dude's ass.
Come on son.
Yeah,
he used it for sexual play.
Come on
from the anal cavity.
Oh my God.
Well,
it takes about 35 years of ass fucking
to take so much dick in your acid wides
it up to take that route.
We're looking at a route that is about
the size of Jamie's whole leg.
Right.
If you had to guess.
Yeah your arm.
No,
go back to that.
Let me say that photo that looks like
more like a leg dude.
It's like a baby,
you know that's like,
that's like tate Fletcher's forearm.
It's like a big giant man's forearm.
That's like my Dick on the opponent
pill.
Right there isn't the same color too
ready to explode like an Oscar Meyer
Wiener.
Did I tell you I use Suntan lotion on my
dick and I actually made my Dick Black
Brown and mean tanner self.
Tanner Tanner.
Cause I did have any lotion and I was
like,
who's tanneries was like an ex
girlfriends.
I'm like well this is lotion.
And so you turned your Dick to block,
turned it to like a orange,
just brownish.
And it was so weird cause it,
it actually changed the color of my
Dick.
Wow.
So between that and the boner pills,
what kind of birth defects you think
your children would have adopting an
Asian girl.
And I'm like,
you're going to go with y'all and style.
Yeah,
I mean,
look,
don't do it.
Raise her to be awesome girlfriend or
was Russian and took this shot.
I was listening to this woody Allen
thing the other day.
It's woody Allen on comedy.
It's really interesting because it's
woody allen.
Uh,
there was,
uh,
two things that I bought.
One of them is woody Allen doing stand
up in like the 1960s.
It's good.
He's good.
He was a very good stand up man.
He was a good comic.
Why shaking your head?
I just hit,
he,
he's a whiner to me.
It wasn't that windy back then.
It wasn't that one you back then.
It was,
um,
it was a different style.
I mean it was,
it was different.
He was a different guy.
He was a young guy and he was known more
of as a comic.
And then there's also,
uh,
an interview where it's just woody allen
talking about the process of creating
comedy and what he did.
And that's kind of after he hits stuff.
Yeah,
that's it right there.
Those are the two of them.
Woody Allen on comedy and then Woody
Allen standup comic.
Those are the two that I was listening
to back to back.
It just,
you know,
I'm not,
certainly not sympathetic to like what
he's done.
I mean,
he's such a fucking Weirdo and what he's
done,
just this,
the fact that that girl was his daughter
and I guess it's so creepy to me write
to everybody,
but looking past that and just trying
to,
uh,
examine him as a human being.
What a,
a,
a complex and weird human being he is.
He's,
he's pretty fascinating.
And I don't think he's victimizing
anybody else,
at least as far as I know.
So I don't,
I don't have any judgment.
I'll just,
whatever.
He's not in jail,
so no one's,
no one's going after him.
So whatever.
I'm,
so,
I'm just watching his life.
I'm just looking at his life and he's
such a fascinating character,
man.
You know,
he is a jazz musician and for awhile he
did,
he did a documentary before everything
got real ugly right where he was going
around.
Was it before everything got real ugly
or was it in the middle of it all?
But he went around playing jazz
concerts.
Like that was always like sort of like
a,
a dream that he had.
So he went around and doing a bunch of
jazz concerts and um,
he writes all of his scripts.
Yeah,
there it is.
Wild Man Blues.
1997 wonder who named it.
Maybe it was ironic,
ironic calling him the wild wild man
blues or is building a wild man.
I wonder when was,
if some of it's,
that's 97.
When did,
um,
all this controversy take place?
I think before this,
right?
Well,
I don't think so because that's 20 years
ago.
So 20 years ago that that girl was like
10.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just weird how we still celebrate
woody Allen,
but yet fucking Cosby,
forget about it.
We celebrate woody Allen macaws.
We forget about it.
Well,
woody Allen seems to have fallen in love
with a girl that he adopted,
which is this crazy.
It was in 1992 when it started as just a
quote filling 23 she responded to
someone paternal.
Woody Allen reveals secret to his 23
year relationship with Mia Farrow's
adopted daughter,
which at first he thought it was just a
fling.
What do y'all and went to [inaudible]
rare details about his relationship with
Sunni.
They got together while he was dating
her adopted mother Mia Farrow.
Now married Sunni 44 and Alan 79 had
been together for 23 years.
Whoa.
I see what she looks like.
So she was 21 when they started getting
it on.
Alan said,
well,
he's 80 there,
dude.
I mean,
she is.
She's half his age and she's 44 she
likes that Daddy Dick.
I mean,
what the fuck man?
Yeah,
she's 44 and he's 79 that is crazy.
She's almost half his age.
Wow.
They'd been together for 23 years.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Go back.
Go down.
No,
go down.
no where it was.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Um,
Alan says it worked because he was
paternal,
which helped her flourish.
And these are in quotes,
paternal and flourish or in quotes.
He also reveals that he thought it would
be just a flame when they started lang.
That mean he just flame raped her or
something.
Oh,
he just got away with fucking his
daughter is when it was weird man.
So where he looks so odd and that photo
too.
And that's 92.
How,
wait,
how old was she when they adopted her?
Like 17 cause then I can get into that.
Was this article from 90 to Jamie?
Nope.
Oh,
published 2015 oh,
why just say 92 now?
The fling started in 1992 oh,
okay.
That makes sense.
Cause how the fuck was she?
Yeah.
Okay.
Then I'm retarded because in 1992 that
makes sense.
Wow.
That's so weird though,
Dude.
So he talks about it now and they've
been married forever.
See that's what's fucked up about it.
What's fucked up about it is it worked.
They've been together for 23 years.
They have children.
Look at that photo of him,
let's scroll down and look at their
photo.
They're smiling there,
arm in arm,
they leave,
they're happy together.
It's fucked up,
but it works.
So I get a certain point in time.
I mean,
it's not,
they're not genetically related,
which is always the big concern.
Right.
The big concern was that your genes
would be,
if you had sex with someone who's your
actual daughter,
your genes be all fucked up and you'd
uh,
oh,
she's kissing him on the cheek.
She seems to love them.
Shovel head.
But you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
it's like,
uh,
we have these ideas of what's,
what's okay and not okay and it's
certainly seems fucked up.
But if she was 21 when it happened,
she was a grown woman and she decided,
you know what,
I want to fuck my dad,
my sort of dad,
the guy who lives across the lives
across the city,
they live in like
opposite sides of the parking or so in
this picture,
I mean,
yeah,
I could see what he was doing.
He was probably fucking her though at
this age.
That's what the problem is as it's
parental,
you know,
he should not be,
he might have like raised her to want
that Dick.
Ooh.
I mean if,
if you can adopt a girl at 17 maybe find
like,
I mean that's not bad.
Right.
Cause it's like if you were like a
parent to a kid for like six months.
Yeah,
I'm well I'm sure that's been done.
Wasn't it like a Ted nugent?
I just,
it wasn't,
it jokingly hinted out for a long time
before they actually came out and said
like,
oh,
I don't know actually,
I don't know.
But Ted nugent did that.
Ted nugent adopted a girl.
So like Google that there was like some
crazy controversy
cause I mean that might not be a bad
deal checking out some of these like
orphanage websites and just finding the
17 year old ones.
Yeah.
It's fun to it.
See if,
uh,
but good.
Just Google that,
you know,
he,
well he wrote songs about like having
sex with young young ladies that were
very young under age.
Ted nugent pick,
Ooh,
yeah.
Legal Guardian.
He became her legal guardian.
That's what it is.
He didn't adopt her.
She was 17 that's exactly head of his
time.
But back then.
Okay.
What year was this when this happened?
All right,
get rid of these photos.
Gross me out.
Um,
what year was that?
[inaudible] 78 78
how much different with things back then
do you take that into consideration?
You have to almost all the time.
It's hard to consider the con.
That's like the context of what's going
on.
Right.
What was the context in the culture at
the time?
Because we were talking about that with
the socrates.
Socrates was,
you know,
they were all pederasts,
they all liked to bang young boys.
It was real common back then.
And,
but yet no one,
no one has a little asterisk next to
everything soccer.
He said you don't say,
but remember he used to bang little
boys,
you know,
but if that was today you would,
so as far as like woody Allen did,
it's creepy,
but is it bad?
It just depends when it started and if
it started when she was 12 or something
like that,
then he could have like totally fucking,
yeah.
Brainwashed her to the point where now
she just thinks she has to be with him
and there was a mia frowns.
Other daughter was saying that he did
something to her too.
But Woody Allen was saying that.
What do be US magazine?
I like,
I'm going to stop right here and talking
about it all day.
Yeah.
Jamie's Colby Bryant's new sneakers road
last day.
Shut your mouth.
How do you even know that 20,000 bucks
to go to that game if you want to go.
What?
He would pay that much money for a
baseball game.
It's basketball.
Yeah.
Who would man crazy
kids from?
They're American but they flew,
they like left Italy to follow them
around all year and it's been a bunch of
money.
They haven't said how much in debt
there,
but they've gone to like 30 plus games
all over the country.
Um,
that's not crazy
fans.
Yes.
A lot of,
a lot of them are Asian though.
He did a really good job marketing
himself in Asia.
Did he,
how did he do that?
Nike.
They took him over there every year in
the off season.
He would go play and do like a
exhibitions and whatnot and they were
doing it to get the Asian market into
the MBA and it worked.
The devil,
they make a lot of money off the Asian
market way more than I would sit and
make the United States.
Obviously there's more people there,
but they love basketball there.
Stephon Marbury left the United States,
went and made a lot of money there.
He's going to retire as like one of the
most famous hall of famers and Chinese
basket.
Well,
what happened to Lynn Sanity?
Obviously I'm on the outside.
I don't hear about that dude anymore.
He's in Charlotte right now.
That's why I'm,
but what's happening?
Is he doing well?
He's okay.
He's just an average,
really good point guard.
What the fuck happened during that one
time where he's just New York and what
was he doing?
He's just kept hitting three pointers or
something.
I'm really good street.
Yeah.
Give like 10 games where he played
extremely well and they needed some
hyped of weight and he was playing into
the hike and it worked out
and now it's over.
It's not that it's over,
it's just there's other things to talk
about.
Yeah.
But how come like me on the outside,
I find out about athletes when they're
in trouble or they do something crazy.
They have to do something like really
good.
Like that's the only time I,
and I remember thinking,
well this guy,
I remember thinking,
well look in there finally.
You know the Asian people have some
super fucking bad ass basketball player
other than the giant guy.
This is what he was doing.
He was like doing the crazy hairstyles
like dragon ball z out his hair this
year.
Crazy spiky hair.
Right.
But like,
like I said,
he's playing in Charlotte,
which is a smaller market.
So there's lot of people talking about
it.
When he was playing in La,
which you did a couple of years ago
after the whole thing happened,
which was a part of getting the Asian
market into play in the NBA and like the
Lakers and there's a lot of Asian people
in la that they could get money off of.
So he was in New York,
he went to La,
played in Houston for a little while,
but now he's stuck in Charlotte,
which is why you don't hear about them.
Okay.
Well also he hasn't been set in the
world on fire.
Right.
And they're not,
they're not one of the top teams,
but they play against the top teams.
Right?
Yeah.
So if he was like super awesome,
you would hear about it.
Right.
And you still do it.
If you tuned into sports center and see
the top 10 or something like that,
you would hear about his name here and
there.
Right.
He's just kind of like four k four k.
What does that mean?
He's okay.
And that was that fun.
And that was a hinchcliffe I okay.
Wow.
Why foe soup?
That's Vietnamese.
He's not Vietnamese.
He was racist.
And not only that,
I don't think it's pho.
I think it's really,
you say Fafa.
Yeah.
Which hey listen,
spell it different.
And why do you think you can get away
with using our words different?
You know you were over here using all
language.
Huh?
What'd you get your own fucking way to
say an r?
So wait,
if it's,
it's
far.
Yeah.
So then why do so many of the pho
restaurants always use it as it's like
pho.
Like cause I know that we're stupid and
we don't bother researching what the
actual word.
It's like how many people called the
hoists?
Gracie Royce Gracie?
Because they were unaware that you have
to pronounce the r like an h when he's
speaking Portuguese.
Yeah.
I like how joey has always hundred
percent says Gyros and I hasta no gyro.
I've been having these fucking gyros
lately.
Dog.
Yeah.
Joey Diaz do whatever he wants.
I liked when he screws up people the
names,
it's half the fun half the fun.
Where the fuck's dom?
Irrera plus beer.
I'm was going to text me.
I was trying to ask you yesterday,
Joe,
about this facebook camera.
What you thought about it.
Whoa.
It's 17 cameras put together in one to
make,
it's called the facebook camera.
They announced it.
They don't,
they're not selling it or anything like
that.
It's going to cost 30,000 bucks to put
it all together,
but supposedly it's going to make
seamless three 60 video.
Holy Shit.
Uh,
so people can watch it.
The guy that,
how long before that flies around?
Yeah.
So if you could put it on a drone,
that'd be pretty,
yeah
dude,
that looks like a Ufo.
I mean this thing that you showing me
right now looks exactly like a classic
Ufo,
doesn't it?
Like if they could figure out how to,
a way to make that like put some sort of
a inside fan makes that thing hover and
move around.
Okay.
They'll,
they'll looks like a Ufo.
They,
they sell one that's like that one that
they sell.
Kind of like at best buy or Amazon
though.
Like it's the same idea where it just
records it,
like write it records like a three 60
thing.
But you can't really do anything with
the video other than the vr.
Yeah.
There's a lot of trouble right now going
into a lot.
When we brought this up the other day,
a lot of people were asking us,
hey,
you guys should do it.
It'd be totally awesome,
which it would be cool for us,
but there's a lot of hurdles to get to.
Well,
you had a real good point too.
We said,
remember when people are going,
how come everything,
is it on three D tv?
What about three d TV while you're doing
your show on three d tv now try to find
a three D tv.
Nobody has one.
The Three d broadcasting was still
probably only did twice.
It's not ready.
Yeah,
none of that stuff's ready.
But I think it's going to be like oculus
rift.
Like it wasn't ready until it's ready.
You know,
like for the longest time when we were
kids,
virtual reality was a thing like there
was even a movie.
Where was it?
Lawnmower man.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
I mean it was based on like we thought,
oh my God,
any day now we're going to be in virtual
reality.
And it never took place because the
computing power and the graphics and
everything just wasn't ready.
But now that it is ready,
like that invidia demonstration that
they did with all the crazy shit that
you can do with a,
um,
with virtual reality and those a oculus
rift goggles.
What is that dude from of iron man that
his lawnmower man really?
Was it that cheesy looking?
Yeah.
No,
it used the same animators from beyond
the mind's eye.
If you ever watched that,
that guy that was in lawnmower man,
the guy on the right,
that dude was in a bunch of movies.
He was one of those movie stars and I
don't remember his name.
Yeah,
I don't know who he is,
but that guy was in some big ass movies.
He was always like the creepy guy.
He's one of those dudes like the dude,
where's my car guy?
I like after he's not doing that,
those movies anymore,
it becomes like,
hey,
or American pie.
The American Pie.
Yeah.
What's l?
Jeff Leahy.
Well,
he's actually pretty famous.
I remember his name.
It's just me.
I forgot his name.
That guy has been in everything though.
Talking about stiffler.
Yeah.
Stiffer.
What happened and stuff.
Like I just saw the video on him
yesterday and why he hasn't been
marketed.
He just had a couple quote unquote bad
roles,
if you will over the movies failed where
he was like a leading man,
but he's been in all the ice age movies.
He's still doing pretty well for
himself,
I'm sure.
Oh,
nice feel good moment,
Jamie.
Beautiful.
All right.
Dom Arrera is going to be here next.
We're going to pause this bitch for a
moment and then bring in the Great Dom
Arrera uh,
these death squad.tv mugs that Brian
brought in.
How long are they for sale for
there?
They've just got a new shipment in,
so they're on,
the big ones are on sale and this shirt,
which is the original death squad shirt,
but it's remixed and hat sent to you via
stamps.com.
That's right.
I'm go to death squad.tv for more info.
Brian is tonight at the Irvine Improv
and tomorrow at the La Jolla comedy
store with George Perez tonight.
Dean Delray,
Joe Hart.
Nick and tomorrow's Sean helping.
Excellent,
excellent comedians.
Excellent show.
Go check that shit out.
Desk squad died.
TV.
Brian is red ban on twitter.
Young Jamie for some reason has not
taken the young Jamie twitter name.
I have it.
It's just I decided not to use it there.
Nonsense seems silly.
It is your name.
You are young.
Jamie.
Someday you're going to be bag.
Bertrand Russell,
they called me young Jamie,
and for the first 50 years I resisted.
The mom gets stuck with the young for my
whole life and it will be you are young,
Jamie.
That's who you are,
bro.
Take it.
I'll take,
okay.
It's a good name.
You're a handsome fella.
All right,
fuckers.
We'll be back in a little bit with the
Great Dom Irrera
okay.
Hmm.
Okay.